في مدينة لوغانو
السويسرية الخلابة ، يعمل العلماء يورجن شميدهوبر
نحو الثورة ، إنه ناجح ،
لن يكون العالم كما هو أبدًا ، كل
هذا سيكون أكثر بكثير من مجرد
ثورة صناعية أخرى ، هذا
سيكون شيئًا يتخطى
البشرية نفسها وحتى علم الأحياء نفسه
شميدت هوبر رائد في مجال
الذكاء الاصطناعي ، هدفه إنشاء ذكاء اصطناعي
أذكى جذريًا من البشر ، وقد
ساعد في تطوير الخوارزميات التي
تحدد المجال كما نعرفه الآن
الذكاء الاصطناعي أو الذكاء الاصطناعي هو ما
يجعل سوريا تستجيب لأوامرك وهذا
ما وجدته ويمكّن Google من
القيام بذلك  ترجمة ما لدينا هنا داخل
مختبرات Schmidt Huber يدفع الذكاء الاصطناعي إلى ما هو أبعد من
أن السيارات تعلم نفسها إيقاف
[موسيقى]
تتعلم الطائرات بدون طيار اتباع البشر حتى أنني أعلم
نفسها لتشغيل الشيء المهم
هو عدم وجود معلم وما
تراه هناك هو محاولة جميع الأنواع  من
الأشياء وفي البداية كان فشلًا تامًا
والهدف هو
زيادة المسافة المقطوعة  د الخطوة التالية في
تطوير الروبوتات التي يمكن أن تعلم
نفسها لأداء مهام بسيطة لا يزال لا
شيء من هذا يقترب من الذكاء الفائق ،
فهذه منصة متنقلة
يعتقد Smid Huber أنه يمكن تحقيقها
في مجرد عقود ، لذلك هناك
من يشككون في القول إن الذكاء الاصطناعي في الواقع
يمكنه  حسنًا ، أدخل نوعًا آخر من
فترة التجميد العميق حيث لا يحدث أي شيء
في الوقت الحالي ، ولا أرى ذلك على أنه
احتمال على الإطلاق لأن كل
الميول التي لاحظتها في مختبري الخاص
في مختبرات أخرى ، يخبرني تسريع الأجهزة بشكل عام
قصة أخرى
القادة الآخرون  في هذا المجال أوافق على أن نيك بوستروم
هو مدير معهد المستقبل الإنساني
في جامعة أكسفورد ، وأعتقد
أنه سيؤثر على جميع جوانب حياتنا
بمجرد الخروج من الاقتصاد.
أنت تعرف حتى الآن ، هل أنت
متفائل بمستقبل البشرية
، أعتقد أن هذا الانتقال إلى
عصر الذكاء الخارق للآلة سيكون بمثابة
يرتبط ببعض المخاطر الكبيرة بما في ذلك
هذه المخاطر الوجودية لانقراض البشر
وما إلى ذلك ولكن على
الجانب الآخر ، وهذا غالبًا لا يحصل على
الكثير من وقت البث ولكن أعتقد أن
هناك هذا الاتجاه الصعودي الهائل يقول شميت هوفر
إنه واثق من أن الاتجاه الصعودي الهائل
سوف يسود  لكنه يعترف بأن الأمر يشبه
اللعب بالنار ، وعلينا أن نكون على دراية
بالمخاطر المحتملة للنار ، لكننا
لن نوقف
التطوير الإضافي للنار لأن الإيجابيات
تفوق السلبيات
التي قد تكون غير متوقعة ، ولكن
يتفق شميدهوبر والآخرون عندما يأتي.  إلى منظمة العفو الدولية
تم ضرب المباراة وبلوكلاند سي إن إن
لوغانو سويسرا